you don't have to be the expert in the
industry to help change people's lives
i'm no expert in homeschooling i'm no
expert in video but i'm just the girl
that decided to step out in courage
and just start talking to a camera let
me ask you this question
what would it feel like to have
unstoppable confidence
what would it feel like to be
comfortable and confident in your own
skin on camera and what would it feel
like to be able to connect with people
as your most authentic self on camera
well we're gonna dive into that and so
much more in today's episode
my name is heather torres and i am your
host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
youtube influence and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit youtube channel well i'm giddy
today because i get to bring you
a behind the scenes clip of one of the
talks that i did at grow with video live
that is our annual conference that we
host here at think
and this year it's actually virtual so
you can get your tickets at
growethvideolive.com but today's episode
is actually a talk that i gave all about
how to have unstoppable
confidence now i believe that your mess
is your message and right now i'm
sitting here
totally confident on camera but let me
tell you friend that is not how i
started
so i'm excited to share this video with
you this talk with you
because i'm going to be breaking down
what my journey was like to where i am
today in my youtube career
how you can apply some of the steps that
i took to
help you get confident on camera and
some of the things that are holding us
back from making
our best content all of that and more is
in today's episode so let's jump into
that
right now
[Music]
grab your notebook grab your pen because
i'm going to give you three power tips
for being confident on camera
right now all right get your pen ready
here we go number one
when you get in front of the camera i
want you to roll your shoulders back
this is something i have to do
every single time i was just doing it
backstage you need to roll your
shoulders back okay
number two i want you to look directly
in
the lens not off to the side not down
not at the little selfie screen that's
on your camera i want you to look
directly
into that lens and the number three is i
want you to take a deep breath let's do
that together right now
and then you press record those three
tips i want you to apply to your next
time
that you are on camera and today's
session we're gonna be talking all about
the art of
confidently connecting on camera and the
think media content
formula we're gonna be walking through
the think media content formula the
mistake you might be making
when you start your videos and what to
do
instead and why you haven't made your
best video yet and
when i bring this to you i want you to
know that
i never thought i would be on camera i
never thought i'd be standing
on a stage speaking to thousands of
people right now
that was not on my agenda for me
entrepreneurship really looked
unclear it looked a lot like this now i
know there's people like sean cannell
and chris decker who
really had a vision for what they wanted
and they knew what they wanted to go
after people like oprah winfrey and elon
musk
you know they really saw what it could
look like
but for me that's what entrepreneurship
looked like
it's kind of foggy kind of hazy i mean i
knew i
wanted to get out there i knew i wanted
to create change in the world
but it never really looked clear
let me know if you can relate to that in
the chat it never really looked
clear i would see other people and i
would think man
i want to do that but i never really
knew what
that was like what was my thing
let me know if you can relate to feeling
like what was my thing
i got married uh early in life but not
early in life i got married
young this is my husband isaiah we got
married 14 years ago and i
knew above anything else that i wanted
to be a mama
we struggled for a few years with
infertility and i birthed two
beautiful children and i remember
thinking as i was lying there
holding my baby breastfeeding in the
middle of the night and really just
thinking about what their life was going
to be like and i thought man
i never want to go back to work i want
to work
but i never want to like go back to work
i don't want to leave my baby
i want to be here i want to see all
these moments i struggled so
hard to finally have children then when
it was time
i wanted to spend time with them
and through the years of being an early
mom
i remember fighting this feeling of mom
guilt as i would do this entrepreneurial
thing or i'd do this freelance thing
and i would always feel like i was just
struggling
let me know if you can relate to this
because i think a lot of times the
journey of an entrepreneur that we see
today
we don't necessarily see these pieces
of knowing that we don't feel like we're
measuring up
feeling like we're stuck in a depressive
state
after i had my second baby i really
struggled with postpartum depression and
really tried to figure out
who am i now now that i'm a wife and a
mother
and someone who wants to do big things
in the world
who am i and i remember juggling kids
and
really literally juggling two children
on my hips yes that was me
and doing countless hours of building
and building
and building while having babies on my
lap
and if that's you right now you're
probably watching i know there's a mom
or two or a dad or two out there and
you've probably got a little one either
sitting
on your lap physically or they're
running around right in front of you
and i just want to speak into you and
say enjoy this season
this is a season for you to be in your
learning season
this is a season for you to be the
person that's most important in their
life
well you're also gaining the skills and
the abilities that you need
for when it's your time to step out and
through that
i knew that i wanted to help people
and walking through postpartum
depression i really discovered that
fitness
was one of the ways i was able to
release how i felt
and throughout my journey of even
understanding
how to change my mindset and how to live
a healthier lifestyle and how to
you know really develop community around
me come on moms that's what you need
around you
i started teaching and i was so blessed
to be able to
start teaching five moms
five moms it started with five moms we
would go to the park and
we would do a workout with our babies in
the strollers
and it started with just seeing small
transformations
in their lives and through that journey
of being able to teach pre and post
pardon i was able to grow that more
and more and more and we created a
village
of women who were supporting each other
who were transforming each other
and throughout that journey i knew wow i
really love
teaching and let me know if you can
relate to the idea of feeling like you
don't know what your thing
is but you know kind of the direction
you want to go in
and so that's what i did i just started
taking step after step
after step kind of falling a little bit
and stumbling a little
bit and feeling like it's just kind of
this black space but i know i'm
headed in the right direction and that's
probably where you are right now
you know you want to do video you know
you want to create content
you know you want to build those pieces
that chris decker just laid out
but you just don't know where you don't
know how
to get there and through
going along and and building up what
that fitness journey looked like
i came across this quote and said the
future belongs to those
who learn more skills and combine them
in creative ways and i was learning
skills i was taking online courses i was
reading books i was
developing my own curriculum of how i
knew i wanted to show up in the world
and that last piece there combining them
in creative ways
and i thought huh how do i want to do
this
creatively how can i be different how
can i stand out
what does that look like and knowing
that i wanted to be with my babies i
knew that the digital age was on the
rise facebook had just released
their online marketing platform they had
just announced that they were going to
be doing
online advertising and i thought aha i
can do that
i could help other small businesses
learn how to use these platforms
it made sense to me i understood
marketing from going to college
but combining that skill in a creative
way and helping small businesses
understand social media that was my
ticket
i knew that's what i needed to do and
through going
along that journey i knew that i needed
to get good people around me
come on you're not going to be doing
this alone you're not going to be able
to walk through this journey of
entrepreneurship
without combining your skills with
someone else's
and i knew back when i was holding those
babies i wanted to help people
and i knew that my ticket to being able
to help you
was if i could just be alongside someone
who had a bigger vision than me
and so our family moved to las vegas and
there was this guy on the internet
making these videos
you know who he is sean cannell he was
just
starting his full-time journey into
youtube and i thought wow
i have these skills of understanding
online marketing and i know that video
is where i need to be next now let me
tell you
i was not confidently saying man i know
i need to be on video
i was saying i need to be on video
well i don't even like what i look like
i mean
my teeth are big i laugh really loud i
always shrug my shoulders i don't really
feel comfortable in my own skin
but i knew i needed to be on video
because video was going to be the
vehicle
to me being able to help people and so i
started to build
the village around me in that way the
same way that i did in my fitness
journey
and i connected with sean cannell and we
decided
that wow our visions matched and i could
help him
create something and i would be able to
be home with my babies
and so from that journey we created
video ranking academy which we have
thousands of students in now
and being along some alongside someone
who has a big vision let me tell you
if you're not connected with someone who
has a bigger vision than you
you need to get in a better room here at
girl with video live there are people in
the chat right now that you need to
connect with
their visions are so big it's scary and
you can help them get there
you might be that person you might be
the entrepreneur that's got the crazy
big vision
where are the people around you who are
going to help you get there and so i
walked through this journey right
every day kind of moving the clouds away
a little bit more and this
the light was shining a little bit more
of where i needed to go
and then i needed to actually learn
video and so omar came onto the team
and i just dove into understanding how
do they create content what do they
think about
you know i come from more of an
analytical brain right i was doing
facebook ads i like this the
spreadsheets and the strategies
but i needed to be around artists i
needed to be around creatives i needed
to think
differently about where i was going and
all the while
i was building my confidence thinking
well if they can do this
i can do this i mean sean shared his
story earlier he was making videos in
his bedroom and i thought
well that's not hard you don't mean you
don't have to like go to school
to understand video and so through that
i grabbed my smartphone and i started
making videos
nothing too scary right i started with
15 second snapchats
but i needed to get comfortable in front
of the camera
i needed to start to understand what
does my voice sound like and
what's the best angle come on you know
what's the best angle
and i would look at these stories and i
would think how do i develop
a daily story not just what's my food
and how are my kids doing
but how can i bring someone along the
journey and i started to see how
omar and how sean how they were creating
these stories
around video and video is so much more
than just grabbing the camera
it really is about understanding how you
get someone from point a to point b
and so through that i started learning
more and i started gaining confidence
and i started doing the reps of video
i need you to write that down because
that's probably your next step
you actually just need to start doing
the reps of making
videos so over time over the years
i would make these snapchat videos and
then
over time working with sean and working
with omar
i was pushed into stepping outside my
comfort zone and starting to actually
making
youtube videos and catalyst that forward
i now uh have videos that have gone
viral on youtube
we started think media at 16 000
subscribers
and now we're at 1.3 million subscribers
that's a lot of people watching videos
and now i'm a host of the think
marketing podcast one of the fastest
growing marketing podcasts in the world
and that all just started from an
unconfident
girl who didn't know what she wanted to
do and all i knew i wanted to do
was help people that's as far as i knew
i didn't see this vision
and so i just want to speak into you and
say if you know that you want to help
people
then your next step is the reps of video
your next step is to actually
get connected to people that you can
help first before you
step out and start doing it so
i wanted to take a second and help you
get
grounded i want you to close your eyes i
know you're like okay heather close my
eyes yes
i need you to close your eyes for this
exercise okay remember what you put in
is what you get out
okay so here's what i want you to do
i want you to close your eyes and i want
you to think
imagine what it would feel like
to have unlimited confidence
imagine what it feels like
to know that you are secure and who god
made you to be
imagine what it would feel like to be
unapologetic
and unashamed of how you look
what your body shape is what the color
of your skin is what the background is
imagine what it would feel like to show
up in the world
just as you what does it feel like
do you see her do you see him
it's critical that you understand that
that feeling that you
just grasped a hold of usually
we don't want to go there because the
fear is too hard
i remember the first time i did this
visualization exercise i thought
yeah okay i could feel confident
but no i really want you to lean in i
really want you to think
what would this actually feel like to
just be me
to just show up to the world the way
that i am
and to help people what does that feel
like
and usually the reason we have fear
alongside that
is because we're stuck inside of our
comfort zone
that little circle that's right around
you right now that you know if you step
out you might fail
if you step out of that circle right
there that you might let someone down
or you might feel like well who am i to
be doing this
i need to tell you friends that what
we're about to do
here at girl with video live it's
outside your comfort zone
you need to step out into the life that
i know
is ready for you so the next thing that
holds us back
is the fear of the gear
when we are going through how do i get
started
how do i get confident on camera usually
i hear this
well yeah i'm going to do that when i
insert by camera get the right lighting
change my hair
get my teeth fixed get a boob job
whatever it is
usually there's some fear attached to it
and the number one fear that we hear
is fear of the gear well i don't know
how to use my camera
well i don't know what the best lighting
is oh yeah i'm gonna wait till i get
that microphone and then i'm gonna do it
right we wrap it into this excuse of the
fear
of the gear but i need to tell you i got
to 1.3
million views on a video by using
an iphone that's right you just got to
get started
you have to start with what you have you
start with
what you already have there are people
right now who are crushing it on video
and they do not even understand how to
use a dslr
or a microphone or anything like that
all you need
is what you have if you're ready to step
outside your comfort zone and you're
ready to actually get
started in video i want you to just grab
your phone today
and make a video that's all you have to
do yes can you upgrade and can you do
things later absolutely
but you need to just start with what you
have and i'm excited because we have a
session coming up with omar
eltacory from the think media team and
he's going to be breaking down
the different gear for every youtube
budget so we're smashing that excuse
today for getting started
and stepping outside of your comfort
zone
and when you get started on video you
need to just
start messy man when i look back at some
of my first videos
it is horrible yes when i look back at
some of my first videos
my voice is up really high like this and
i'm so nervous and it took me
so long to make the video and so long to
edit the video
and i just had to realize that it's not
going to be perfect and you have to
start
messy when you get started hear me you
need to just start
messy that will help you to break the
excuse
of actually getting started if you have
a smartphone if you have a webcam
you can start making videos right now
your first videos are going to be your
worst videos
yeah your first videos will be your
worst videos did you see sean's first
video
yeah it's not like he's sean of today he
was shot a decade ago sitting there
saying i want to be
unentertaining and un you know i this is
not like
no no no you're gonna start messy your
first videos are gonna be your worst
videos so let's get those
out of the way and here's what my first
videos look like
the first one you can tell it's on a
webcam and what am i doing
i'm not even doing the power tip i told
you about i'm not even
looking at the camera yes that is me
in my bedroom i put a couch behind me
i've got headphones on it's the worst
audio
i was so nervous i did not even look at
the camera
yes i put it out there thousands of
views
on that video your first videos they're
probably gonna be your worst videos
now next image is me standing there on a
box we were doing a live training that
was my first time actually
live training like i'm doing right now
and you'll notice i'm standing there on
this box i'm standing on a box
why well because sean's like six three
and i'm five five i look like a child
compared to him
so when we stand next to each other and
teach i have to stand on a box
so there's some behind the scenes for
you but you'll notice my arms
they're like this right like see my arms
i literally taught for like an hour like
this why
because i was so nervous that i had pit
stains
and so i had to keep my arms in like
this because i was like well if i move
my arms they're gonna see this
you gotta start messy friend that's what
you need to do if i can do this
you can do this you'll notice i'm
wearing a black shirt if you came from
our youtube influence challenge you know
that there's a reason for a black shirt
right
it covers the pit stains that's a tip
for you you're welcome
but this is also what mike and catherine
did he started
messy now mike just grabbed a camera he
got started i think it was like 480i
it's
like the blurriest camera look at the
camera quality i mean no lighting
he's like walking through products that
you need but mike
just started your first videos are going
to be
your worst videos now i love mike i love
catherine
they now have a great videographer
that's helping them but they just got
started with what they had
i don't even think it was even as great
of quality as like an iphone
it literally was like the worst camera
you could get sean says it looks like
it's done on a baked potato
but mike and catherine they're getting
10
million views a month
what would that do to your family what
would that do for your influence
whether it's a crappy camera or the best
camera what would that do for your
message
to be getting 10 million
views a month and like i said i'm
excited because mike is going to be
telling us how he did it
on that youtube uh for business panel
now here's something i need you to know
you do not need permission
to start on youtube did you know that
in the society that we leave it live in
we think we need someone to tell us that
it's okay to get started
hear me friend it's okay to get started
on youtube it's okay to start picking up
your phone and making
videos you do not need permission to do
this
you are already qualified sean teat us
up in that first session he said what
are you good at
what are you passionate about you
are already qualified my question to you
is are you a few steps ahead of someone
else
you know when i started my homeschooling
channel here on youtube
i was so scared i i like there's no
other way to say it i was
so scared of judgment i was scared of
not
being qualified enough i was like i mean
i'm just starting i don't even know what
i'm doing
but there are moms who needed what i had
they needed to hear my perspective on
why we chose to homeschool and what
curriculum we decided to do
i'm not an expert in homeschooling by
any means but i know enough
to help the mom next to me do you know
enough to help the person next to you
are you just a little bit further along
in the journey and you wish there was
someone like you
that could have helped you along the way
not make the same mistakes to speak life
into you to give encouragement
to tell you what to buy and what not to
buy that's what you can do when you
start messy
it's not about you it's about them so i
want you to pick up the camera
and get started but your next question
might be
well okay heather but how do i actually
make a video
i mean maybe right now you're already
making videos maybe you're on the
platform
already making videos but maybe
you're like half the people that are
here and you haven't even started yet
so i'm gonna tell you our think media
content formula
but the first thing you need you to know
is that we actually have put together
two amazing videos for you over on
youtube where
we're gonna show you step by step in 30
minutes how to actually
make a video edit the video make the
thumbnail and
upload it to youtube all using
your phone we're cracking your excuses
today on actually getting started
and if you're a little bit more advanced
we have another video for you where
shawn walks you through how to
make the video how to edit the video on
premiere how to make a thumbnail on
photoshop
and then how to release that video on
youtube you can get the links for those
from our team
but that's where you need to go if you
want to know how do i make the video
like how do i actually
make the cake heather that's how you do
it but i want to show you here what we
call
our think media video formula now there
are teachers out there that i really
believe
completely over complicate the idea of
making videos
there is a secret recipe to making
videos and it only includes
three things if you're like me and you
don't actually love to cook i'm
literally a box cooker i need someone to
tell me you only need to add oil eggs
and water
that is what we're doing here today on
the think media video
formula this is not some magical formula
but this is
proven over and over and over for not
just us here at think media
we've tested this with so many different
types of niches and videos
this is the secret sauce to making
videos so i need you to lean in
it's going to start with a hook we're
going to walk through number one which
will be
the hook and then you put your content
in
and the last thing you do is your call
to
action write those down you need your
hook your content
and your call to action now let's break
this down the hook
well what is a hook the hook's purpose
is to grab attention
and convince your viewer to watch the
rest of the video
that is the entire intention of the hook
now the hook is exactly what you start
when you start the video that is
where your hook belongs and i'm going to
give you something called our swipe copy
what is that
it means we're literally giving you the
fill in the blanks you remember those
from school
you would get the whole thing and you
just have to fill in the one word that's
what i'm giving you today so you can
make
your video today all right so what is a
swipe copy
for the hook well here's one of them
it's called the clarity hook
in this video i'm going to show you how
to fill in the blank
our friend cami is here today she's
running growth video live
and her hook is in this video i'm going
to show you
how to make cauliflower rice
wow i know exactly what i'm doing
remember we need to grab attention
and we need to want them to watch the
video all the way through
now the reason you want to make your
hook intriguing
and the clarity is because when someone
goes through and clicks your thumbnail
they've seen your thumbnail and your
title
you want them to immediately know
they're in the right place
let me know if you've watched videos
like this you click on the video and
this week here
hey guys thank you so much for being
here i'm so excited that you're watching
my video it's been so long like i had to
take my cat to the vet and
like everything got crazy but yeah you
know i'm back here and i'm super excited
because you're here so click that
subscribe button right now
wow that is not how you want to start a
video
i don't even know if i'm in the right
place and i also don't really care about
your cat
so when you start your hook on a video
it needs to be a punchy
and a clarity hook is so great because
it allows someone to know
i'm in the right place this is my girl
this is who i need to learn from
now the next one is the problem solution
hook the problem
solution hook and here's what you start
with are you struggling with
x what is x what are they struggling
with what keeps them up at night
in this video i'm going to teach you
share with you explain to you how to
blank this is powerful
because someone is coming to youtube
they're typing in the search bar
they have a problem and guess what
you're bringing them
the solution this is powerful because as
someone is
going and scrolling through they want
you to know wow
they know me they get me she gets me so
the problem solution hook is a
valuable hook to use okay now you have
two options
either you do the clarity hook or the
problem solution hook in your first
video the next thing we're going to talk
about is the content
this is what i call the meat and
potatoes of your video
your content is critical i need you to
be planning out your content
before you press record if there's one
mistake i see
a lot of video creators making it's
they're just turn on the camera
and just think they're gonna wing it let
me tell you winging it is not the way
you need to be planned and have a
purpose for every
video we're going to jump into the
content now the content
i suggest that you script an outline we
get asked here at think media do you
guys read off of teleprompters what do
you do
i usually bullet point my points that
i'm going through when i'm doing a video
i know what number one is
what number two is and what number three
is and you'll notice number two
is number your points or steps now this
is a great piece of psychology
that when you tell someone they're gonna
learn five things they're usually
going to stick around in the video to
actually watch
five things right if i were to come to
you and say don't make these seven
mistakes
well won't you want to watch all seven
to make sure you don't make those
mistakes
so when you number your points in steps
you actually increase
your retention rates on your videos
and then the next thing is you want to
make your videos as
long as they need to be but as short as
possible
when you're getting started on video it
is not recommended that you start with
45 minute videos it's not recommended
for you to stay consistent with that
and it's not recommended for your
audience to just come in watching long
form videos
you want to be punchy you want to get
the point across you want to go
on dates with people throughout your
videos
that's what it's like when people say
i've been binge watching your videos
that's like going on many dates
exchanging a handshake
having a cup of coffee going to the zoo
like all of those things
yeah going to the zoo that was my
example all of those things
are critical when you're walking through
your content so i want you to be brief
be bright be fun and be done
on your video and how do you end the
video well you start with the hook
you give them the content and then you
give a call to
action or a cta in marketing lingo
now a call to action you need to tell
someone where to go next
where do they need to go next you don't
just end the video hey subscribe to my
video like my video do all these things
with my video
you need to say hey if you enjoyed this
video
then the next one you need to watch is
this one
tell them where you want them to go in a
relationship when you are communicating
with
a partner there's always the back and
forth right like you want to be
overly communicating with a partner same
thing goes with video
going into video and going into the
online space and being an entrepreneur
like sean said
is being a problem solver and i'm sure
you probably solve more than one problem
and so people need to know what is my
next step that i need to take
with you you can send them to another
video you can send them to a free
download we're going to talk about
building your email list later on
or something like schedule a call if you
have a service based business
like one of the dentists that we're
gonna share with you later on
he pushes people to giving him a call so
he can schedule a dental appointment
with them
and again when you start on video
i want you to remember this over and
over again
you need to just start messy
but what if you're still struggling
you're like okay heather got it i need
to step out of my comfort zone
i need to make a video with a hook a
content a cta i'm writing all this stuff
down
great but when it's time to get the
camera out
when it's time to hook up the microphone
when it's actually
time to start the youtube video
what if you're still being held back i
want you to journal this
what is holding you back from making
your
best videos not just making videos
because i've given you now what you need
to do
but what's holding you back from
actually making
your best videos
and i believe that one of the things
that we as entrepreneurs
love to say is
well i'm i'm a perfectionist
yeah do you feel that one is that you
too
yeah i mean it's just not perfect yet
perfectionism is probably holding you
back from making your best videos
perfectionism is wrapped in fear
it's a beautiful pretty word to say i'm
actually scared of failure
i'm actually scared that someone's going
to judge me i'm actually scared that i'm
going to get
a rude comment i'm actually scared that
they're actually going to call out that
i have big teeth
perfectionism might be holding you back
and i love this quote by brene brown she
says perfectionism
is a 20-ton shield that we lug around
thinking it will protect us when in fact
it's the thing that's really preventing
us from taking
flight and she says authenticity
is the daily practice of letting go
of who you think you're supposed to be
that's perfectionism
it's who you think you're supposed to be
and embracing who you are
and if you know my message if you've
been around think media i need to tell
you this
you are enough
you are already enough you do not need
to let the perfectionism the fear of
failure the fear of judgment
hold you back you
are enough what does enough mean
it means you're worthy of this it means
that
you already have it inside of you to do
this
it means that you show up for your life
unapologetically about who you are
what your voice is what your message is
it means that
beautifully and messy we show a broken
and bruised
but you're enough for this i need you to
hear this
i don't know if someone's told you
before you can't do this
who are you why do you think this could
be what you do
why don't you get a real job have you
heard those
i need to speak this into you you
are enough
you already have this in you you can
show up
confidently and boldly and courageously
not for you but for the people you need
to help
they are waiting for you on the other
side
of your fear your fear is holding you
back from changing
their life it is not about you me being
on this stage
right now i am not scared because i know
that i have a message
that needs to get to you and that
message says you are enough
this is for you i believe that you were
born in this time
with this technology with this message
inside of you
right now on purpose you were made on
purpose
for a purpose you are enough
you are worthy you are ready to step
out and get your message to the world
you need to just start
messy you need to know that right now
it's your time you are here at growth
video live 2020 and i believe that is on
purpose
i believe that when you set the
intention that for this next year you're
going to be committed to growth
you're going to be committed to being a
leader that that
is what is actually going to change it
may not be the subscriber count it may
not be the money it may not be the
accolades
but what's going to change is you
because what you do in obscurity
is actually going to prepare you for
popularity
and if you don't feel like you're enough
today when the pressure
and the fame and the money and all of
that is there because
let me tell you i believe it that it is
there for you
but when it gets there is it all going
to come crumbling down
are you not going to be able to hold up
with your character and your integrity
and your intention
because when you were in obscurity when
it was five moms for me
were you preparing yourself for
popularity
you need to build yourself up if no
one's talking this into you i need you
to write it out every day
i am enough i need you to put it on a
shirt like i did i
am enough you are enough you can do this
but you have to just start messy
so maybe it's perfectionism that's
holding you back it's the fear of
failure it's the fear of not
feeling like you can do this and again
remember me
sweaty me looking not in the camera me
i'm here today speaking to you because i
just put in the reps
because i just believed in my voice
because i boldly stepped out in courage
and said she needs me he needs me he
needs to know that
my mess is my message
the reason that i'm speaking confidence
into you is because that woman that you
saw holding those two babies had zero
confidence
i hated how i looked i hated what i was
saying
i hated i hated that i just didn't i
wasn't living up to my god-given
potential
and so i just need to speak it to you
today that you can do this
you have it in you and you are enough
you just have to start messy just the
way that mike did
and then what happens over time as
you're practicing as you're building
your community as you're helping more
people
what happens over time is things like
this
i just talked to mike the other day him
and his family they're in hawaii right
now
living on a property that they were able
to purchase because
they invested their time in growth and
knowing
that the message they had and the
products that they had
that they're worth it and now their
family is in hawaii and they're living
the best life
because he just kept going and he just
started
messy maybe number two for you is
actually this one
maybe the thing that's holding you back
for making your best videos
is that you feel like an imposter who am
i to be making these videos
why should someone care what i have to
say i'm not the most
talented and i'm not really the expert
in this
and imposter syndrome is really wrapped
in the idea
that you actually don't believe in what
you're doing
do you know how to make great food then
make the youtube video about it
are you a mom with six kids and you know
how to actually run a household
make the youtube videos about it you
don't have to be the
expert in the industry to help change
people's lives
i'm no expert in homeschooling i'm no
expert in video
but i'm just the girl that decided to
step out in courage
and just start talking to a camera
that's what i know is ready and waiting
for you on the other side of you
stepping out
of your comfort zone getting rid of
impostor syndrome and just saying you
know what
i'm going to start by just helping the
people i have i'm going to start by
helping
the people around me and then from there
it'll grow and i'm going to help those
people
and from there it'll grow and i'm going
to help those people and i'm gonna think
about it like this
i'm just gonna lead if there's one thing
that we need in this world right now it
is more
leaders so i'm just gonna lead well i'm
gonna be someone's best friend
you know that friend that you call who's
really great at makeup like my friend
jane
i love that she's great at makeup
because i'm not and she's not an
expert at makeup she's my best friend
who does makeup
and so i'm going to call her when i when
i need makeup
or what about a helper you know back
when we used to live in communities with
our parents
way back in the day there was always
like that mom
right that that mom that could help with
anything maybe you're the helper
you don't necessarily need to be the
expert in your industry
but maybe you qualify under one of these
different things you're a leader
a best friend a guide instead of
stepping into not feeling like an expert
give yourself a title like this and
start making videos
because i believe that you are braver
than you believe
you are stronger than you seem and you
are smarter
than you think you are brave you are
bold
you are courageous you've been through
things
you are stronger than you seem
when you fall down i want you to pick
yourself back up
i know that this year has been hard for
so many people
and as you walk through what it could
look like in the future i want you to
remember
that you've got it in you to get back up
when you've been
kicked in the face and you know what
that feels like
that success on the other side is so
much sweeter
and i believe that you're smarter than
you think if there's a message i want
you to leave with today it's the idea
that
you are smart
maybe someone in your past has told you
you're dumb you're stupid
i am here to tell you from the growth
video live stage on the camera
into your home that you
are smart you figured it out to this
point in your journey
you can figure it out from here all you
need to do is change your mindset of how
you see yourself
and that will get you through it and the
last thing chris touched on this
is comparison maybe what's holding you
back for making your best
videos and connecting confidently on
camera
is the idea that you're comparing
yourself to someone else
man this is my hardest one i go through
instagram
and i'm like wow look what she's doing
wow
look what he's doing and comparison is
the thief
of joy sink that in
let it sink in comparison
is the thief of joy
don't you want to live a joyful life
when you think about what today could be
i want to lead with joy through the
heartache
through the through through the struggle
choose joy and when you go into
comparison
comparison is the thief of that joy
like chris said when you start comparing
your beginning to someone else's middle
that's where you get misaligned and so
here's what i want you to do
i want you to start unfollowing
yep that's right i want you to go
through instagram
and i want you to go through facebook
and i want you to go through the social
media apps
and if you start to feel that rise up of
comparison
i want you to actually click unfollow
because it's not healthy for you
as a content creator to always be living
in this struggle
of you not being good enough you are
good enough
and so what i need you to do today is go
through your instagram
and just start unfollowing people it
doesn't mean you don't love them i mean
i unfollow some of my best my best
friends why
because i start to feel that comparison
creep up and i know that
right now i need to be in a space where
i can help you
and so if i'm comparing myself to other
people that's actually not helping me
move forward
so remember this you have the ability
to just unfollow
and going through these three enemies
and a lot of times in entrepreneurship
it really sometimes just feels like
you're alone feels like maybe you're the
only one that's struggling with these
things
i bring these things up and usually uh
i'll get back from people in the crowd
like i'll see the head shakes
i know you're shaking your head it's
perfectionism
it's comparison it's impostor syndrome
usually those are the things that are
holding you back
and i want you to take a moment right
now
if you're in the chat if you're on the
discussion if you're writing something
down i want you to just take a second
and i want you to get in the chat
and as i walk through these questions i
want you to
think about wow this applies to me and
if it does
i want you to drop a red emoji
because as we walk through this
entrepreneurial journey
you need to know that you are not alone
you're not alone in feeling like this
and right now if you're in the chat
here's what i want you to answer
have you ever felt like you don't
measure up if that's you right now i
need you to drop a red emoji
have you ever felt like you don't
measure up on camera
have you ever felt like your ideas
aren't good enough
i need you to drop an emoji in the chat
have you ever felt insecure when you
press that record button
that sounds like you i need you to drop
an emoji in the chat
have you ever allowed fear
to keep you from getting started
if that's you i need you to drop an
emoji in the chat
and have you ever felt not enough
like you don't have what it takes
i'll bet the chat right now is fired up
because you're not alone in this we all
struggle with these things
this is all part of the journey you're
not gonna make it to
success without the struggle
these are the pieces behind the scenes
of entrepreneurship
getting over things like comparison
imposter syndrome
being able to step out boldly in who you
are and who god created you to be
if this is you if you feel like i'm just
doing this alone you're not alone
there's people from around the world
right now who are firing up the chat
because they want you to know that
you're not doing this alone
you've got this in you you have
greatness
inside of you i believe this friend
i believe that this is the ripple effect
in our world that we need right now
like when you stone when you throw a
stone into water
and that stone starts to ripple out and
ripple out
and ripple out that's what's happening
here at growth video live
we're throwing the stone in but you're
the ripple
so i need you to step up boldly i need
you to have courage i need you to be a
leader
in your family in your household in your
community
it is important that you understand that
you are made for this
for this time in history you are going
to be the vehicle
for change you need to grab the camera
you need to get over the fear you need
to step out poop your pants scared
sweaty armpits and all and just get
started you've got to start messy friend
this is your year i know it is
thank you well i hope that talk
brought you value i hope that you got
your journal out and you were taking
some notes and
i'm just curious did you feel like any
of those enemies were holding you back
for making your best content
i shared in that that you know for me
it's about perfectionism
it's about imposter syndrome and really
it's about just the lack of confidence
and so many of those things i've seen
throughout my youtube journey from not
just myself
but from other content creators who are
held back
by feeling like they're an imposter or
feeling like they don't really know
what to do on youtube so i hope that
this brought you encouragement
and just a sneak peek of the type of
content you're going to be getting at
grow with video live
now this year we've taken so much
feedback over the last few years
about what you're looking for in a
virtual conference
and one of the things that we're going
to be doing this year are
ted talks so short segments of just
one action step that you can take a lot
of times the content is so rich that you
feel like
at the end your journal's just full and
we want to make sure that you've got the
step-by-step
action steps to grow your channel this
year
so we're going to be doing that this
year at grow with video live we've also
included
a lot of networking time let me know in
the comments if you're watching on
youtube or over
on the reviews on apple if getting to
know other content creators
is something that's important to you i
know when i first started on youtube
i kind of felt alone on this journey no
one in my family knew what i was doing
and my friends outside of think media
had zero clue
about working on youtube so if you kind
of feel alone and you want to connect
with other people who are doing what
you're doing
then grow with video live is going to be
the place for you
we've set aside networking time so that
you can get to know people who are in
the same stage as you
maybe in the same niche as you or maybe
someone you can partner or collaborate
with
in the future so we've got that
networking time set aside
we have so many things planned for you
along with giveaways
games and so much more at this year's
grow with video
live so get your affordable ticket today
at growethvideolive.com
you can attend virtually from anywhere
in the world
and i cannot wait to see you on screen
at growth video live
this year in august of 2021.
now our podcast listeners know that this
is the time
of my favorite part of the podcast where
i get to connect with you
the listener through our apple review
i want to encourage you to rate and
review the podcast because it not only
helps both boost my confidence by seeing
the things you're writing
i mean is that truth can i just tell you
it brings me so much joy to know that
you're getting value out of this
but also it helps other content creators
know
that this is the place for them we want
to create this experience here at think
where everyone is welcome
but that they know that this is where
they should be if they want to get
serious about growing their youtube
channel
today's review comes from dark blue 892.
i like that name uh they said best con
best podcast for brand building
i can't say enough good things about the
think media team i mean come on that is
a confidence booster thank you so much
darkblue892
what i will say is if you're building
your personal brand you
need to listen to this podcast sean
heather
and the team consistently over sell
value in this community love you guys
hey
blue dark blue 892. here's me throwing a
heart emoji out at you
that all rhymed wow that was really cool
anyways
thank you for being a part of our think
community thank you for
sharing what you're learning on the
podcast and for encouraging others
to dive into the episodes that we have
here
i want to say again if you're not
subscribed use this opportunity right
now to click the subscribe button
wherever you're consuming this content
from
so that next week's episode will show up
for you in
your feed i want to thank you again for
being a part of our think community
thank you so much for being a content
creator that's taking action
and that's being a force for change in
this world
thanks for being a part of our movement
here at think and i can't wait to see
you at growth video live
2021. i'll see you in the next episode
bye not growing on youtube learn the
newest strategies for getting views and
the best proven ways to make money
at grow with video live a two-day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growthvideolive.com
you